بدات في البرازيل اليوم اسطوره كره القدم
البرازيلي الراحل البيلي التي تستمر 24
ساعه وقد وصل جثمان اللاعب الراحل الى
ملعب فريقي مدينه سانتوس وسط اجراءاتها من
المشدده تمهيدا لمراسم القائم نظره
الاخيره على جثمانه
الراحل سينقل الى مقبره سانتوس سال عموديه
في مدينه مرور مرورا بشوارعها ثم الى منزل
والدته حيث من المقرر اجراء الدفن بحضور
افراد العائله والمقربين فقط وقد توفي
بلال عن عمرنا هذا 82 عاما بعد صراعا مع
مرض سرطان القولون
من ملعب فريق مدينه سانتوس البرازيليه
مراسل الجزيره حسان مسعود اذا مراسم تابين
في ملعب سانتوس ما هي ال الاجراءات الاخرى
التي ستحيط بهذه الجنازه واين يوجد جثمان
بيليه
ملعب مدينه سانتوس هذا الملعب الذي يشكل
رمزيه كبيره في مسيره النجم الراحل اسطوره
كره القدم البرازيليه بيليه همم هذا
الملعب الذي احتضنه لمده 18 عاما لعب على
ارضيه هذا الملعب وشاهده الجمهور الذين
كانوا يحضرون بالالاف الى هذه المدرجات
حيث نتواجد الان وهم الان يودعونه من ذات
المدرجات من ذات ارضيه الملعب اين هي همم
جثه او جثمان الراحل هذه التي سنظر اليها
الان تحت الخيمه في هذه اللحظات يوجد
النجم الاسطوره بيليه تحت هذه الخيمه وفي
هذه الاثناء يزوره رئيس اتحاد كره القدم
الدوليه الفيفا الذي ربما سيظهر معكم في
الصوره
ويلقي عليه نظره الوداع وكذلك
جانبي وفد من اتحاد كره القدم وعدد من
المؤيدين المحبين الجمهور الذين ياتون الى
هنا يتوافدون لالقاء التحيه الاخيره لا
ادري ان كنتم ترون النعش الان يتم فتح
النعش همم ايضا بشكل اوضح امام رؤيه وتحيه
الجمهور للنجم الراحل بيليه همم هذه هي
اللحظات الاخيره الساعات الاخيره التي
سيتمكن فيها محب النجم بلاي همم بكل من
تابعه على مدار هذه المسيره الطويله التي
استمرت ل 60 عاما في كره القدم وفي
ارتباته بكره القدم على مستوى العالم
النجم الذي همم صنف على انه رياضي القرن
من قبل لجنه اللجنه الاولمبيه العالميه
همم القرن ال 20 وكذلك
حاز على لقبي لاعب القرن بالشراكه مع
النجم الارجنتيني الراحل وهو بالمناسبه
صديق مقرب لبليه همم النجم دييغو ارماندو
مارادونا وهمم بعد رحيل النجم مارادونا
قبل عامين نحن نودع اليوم والعالم يودع
اليوم النجم والصوره كره القدم اسطوره
القرن العشرين همم
سمنتو الشهير بيبيليه طبعا همم على ارضيت
هذا الملعب ملعب همم سانتوس وكذلك همم على
همم امتداد مسيرته الكرويه مع نادي سانتوس
سجل بيليه امام معدله اكثر من هدف في كل
مباراه هذا يعني انه عندما كان يشارك في
اي مباراه مع سانتوس كان يسجل هدفا كان قد
شارك بحوالي 600 واربعه مباريات وسجل
حوالي 650
هدفا في مبارياته مع نادي سانتوس زين
عندما كان بيلين يريد الانتقال عام 58 من
نادي سانتوس الى ايطاليا حيث يحترف عاده
نجوم كره القدم البرازيليه في تلك الفتره
ووقع بالفعل عقدا مع نادي انتر ميلان حدثت
ثوره حقيقيه من قبل مشجعين نادي سانتوس
هنا في هذه المدينه همم نزلوا الى الشوارع
هدفوا ضده هذا القرار فالطر نادي انتر
ميلان
لالغاء هذا العقد وللعوده عن قراره واستمر
في اللعب بشكل حصريا مع نادي سانتوس لمده
18 عاما الى ان انتقل الى نادي كوزموس
الامريكي في نهايه مسيرته الكرويه لمده
سنتين فقط ومن الجدير ايضا بذكره ان اا
بلاي عندما همم شارك في مباراته الاخيره
في مباراه الاعتزال هناك على ارضيه نادي
ااا كوزموسيل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بعدما كان قد ادخل حب كره القدم الى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه شارك في
مباراه رمزيه نصف المباراه الشوط الاول
كان قد شاركت الى جانب فريق نادي كوزموس
والفريق الثاني همم النصف الثاني الشوط
الثاني شارك مع نادي سانتوس هذا النادي
الذي يحتضنه اليوم ويحتضنه نعشه اليوم
تخيل هذه العلاقه الكبيره حتى اللحظات
الاخيره اللي همم في همم علاقته مع نادي
سانتوس وهذه الفعليه وهي اخر نقطه ستستمر
لمده 24 ساعه حتى همم القيام بدفن يوم غد
الثلاثاء طبعا همم البدايه كانت من نادي
سانتوس وهو يودع همم العالم من نادي
سانتوس ايضا همم
اللافته خلفت مباشره تقول كل شيء همم يحيى
او عاش الملك
حبيبي شكرا جزيلا لك حسان مسعود من ملعب
نادي سانتوس